[Music]
so one of my favorite lines from Ernest
Becker's book the denial of death is the
notion that character is a vital lie
right so of course the self is a house
of cards constructed with you know
interconnected webs of meanings cultural
affiliations stereotypes you know
artificial renderings about who we are
as we navigate in this world we
construct self-esteem we construct a
foundation so that we can stand with
dignity but ultimately it's all a lie
human beings are food for worms the fact
that we're gonna die in views even our
greatest ecstasy's with the steam with a
burn that's such a good life and so when
he says character is a vital lie he
inserts the word vital in there as if to
say noble man is noble even if he is
doomed man is noble even if he is worm
food therein lies our beautiful therein
lies our tragedy and therein lies the
the anxiety that you know eats me up
from inside at times and probably what
pushes me to try to make art
[Music]